so the other morning I went to the
grocery store and an employee greeted me
with a good morning sir can I help you
with anything I said no thanks I'm good
person smile then we went our separate
ways I grabbed Cheerios and I left the
grocery store and I went through the
drive-through of a local coffee shop and
after I placed my order the voice on the
other end said thank you ma'am drive
right around now in the span of less
than an hour I was understood both as a
sir and as a ma'am and but for me
neither of these people are wrong but
they're also not completely right this
cute little human is my almost two year
old Elliot yeah all right and over the
past two years this kid has forced me to
rethink the world and how I participate
in it identify as transgender and as a
parent and that makes me a transparent
[Laughter]
as you can see I took years this year's
SEMA went super literal like any good
dad joke should so more specifically
identify as genderqueer and now there
are lots of ways to experience being
genderqueer but for me that means I
don't really identify as a man or a
woman
I feel in-between and sometimes outside
of this gender binary and being outside
of this gender binary means that
sometimes I get surd and ma'am in the
span of less than an hour when I'm out
doing everyday things like getting
Cheerios but this in-between land is
where I'm most comfortable this space
where I can be both a sir and a man
feels the most right in the most
authentic but it doesn't mean that these
interactions aren't uncomfortable
trust me that discomfort can range from
minor annoyance to feel like physically
unsafe at the time at a bar in college
when a bouncer physically removing by
the back of the neck is threw me out of
a woman's restroom but for me
authenticity doesn't mean comfortable it
means managing and negotiating the
discomfort of everyday life even the
times when it's unsafe and it wasn't
until my experience as a trans person
collided with my new identity as a
parent that I understood the depth of my
vulnerabilities and how they were
preventing me from being my most
authentic self now for most people what
the child will call them is not
something that they gave much thought to
outside of culturally specific words or
variations on a gendered theme like mama
mommy or daddy Papa but for me the
possibility is with this child who will
grow to be a teenager and then a
real-life adult will call me for the
rest of our lives with us was both
extremely scary and exciting and I spent
nine months wrestling with a reality
that being called mama or something like
it didn't feel like me at all and no
matter how many times their versions of
mom that I tried it always felt forced
and deeply uncomfortable I knew being
called mom or mommy would be easier to
digest for most people the idea of
having two moms is not super novel
especially where we live so I tried
other words and when I played around
with daddy it felt better better but not
perfect it felt like a pair of shoes
that you really liked but you needed to
wear and break in and I knew the idea of
being a female born person being called
daddy was going to be a harder road with
a lot more uncomfortable moments but
before I knew it the time had come and
Elia came screaming into the world like
most babies do and my new identity as a
parent began I decided on becoming a
daddy and I knew family face the world
now one of the most common things that
happens when people meet us is for
people to mom me and when I get moms
there are several ways that interaction
can go and I've drawn this math to help
help illustrate my options so option one
is to ignore the assumption and allow
folks to continue to refer to me as mom
which is not awkward for the other party
but it's typically really awkward for us
and it usually causes me to restrict my
interaction with those people option one
option two is to stop and correct them
and say something like actually I'm
Elliot's dad or Lda calls me daddy and
when I do this one or two of the
following things happen folks take it in
stride and say something like oh okay
then move on or they respond by pologize
it profusely because they feel bad or
awkward or guilty or weird but more
often what happens is folks get really
confused and look up with an intense
look and say something like does this
mean you want to transition do you want
to be a man or say things like how can
she be a father only men can be dads
well option one is oftentimes the easier
route option two is always the more
authentic one in all of these scenarios
involve a level discomfort even in the
best case and I'll say that over time my
ability to navigate this complicated map
has gotten easier but the discomfort is
still there now I won't stand here and
pretend like I've mastered this it's
pretty far from it and there are days
when I still allow option one to take
place because option two is just too
hard or too risky
there's no way to tell that or to be
sure of anyone's reaction and I want to
be sure that folks have good intentions
that people are good but we live in a
world where someone's opinion of my
existence can be met with serious
threats to me or even my family's
emotional or physical safety
so I weigh the I weigh the costs against
the risks and sometimes the safety of my
family comes before my own authenticity
but despite this risk
I know as Elliott gets older and grows
into her consciousness consciousness and
language skill
if I don't correct people she will I
don't want my fears and insecurities to
be placed on her to dampen her spirit or
make her question her own voice I need
to model agency authenticity and
vulnerability and that means means
leaning into those uncomfortable moments
of being mom'd and standing up and
saying no I'm a dad and I even have the
dad jokes to prove it now there are even
plenty of uncomfortable moments and even
some painful ones but there's also been
in just two short years validating and
at times transformative moments on my
journey as a dad and my path towards
authenticity when we got our first
sonogram we decided we wanted to know
the sex of the baby the technician saw a
vulva and slapped the words it's a girl
on the screen and gave us a copy and
sent us on our way we shared the photo
with her families like everyone does and
soon after my mom showed up at our house
with a bag filled and I'm not
exaggerating it was like this high and
it was filled and overflowing with pink
clothes and toys now it was a little
annoyed to be confronted with a lot of
pink things and having studied gender
and spent countless hours teaching about
it in the workshops and classrooms I
thought it was pretty well-versed on the
social construction of gender on how
sexism is a devaluing of the feminine
and how it manifests both explicitly and
implicitly but this situation this
aversion to a bag full of pink stuff
forced to force me to explore my
rejection of highly feminized things in
my child's world I realized that I was
reinforcing sexism and the cultural
norms I teach is problematic no matter
how much I believe in gender neutrality
in theory in practice the absence of
femininity is not neutrality its
masculinity if I only dress my baby in
greens and blues and grays the outside
world doesn't think oh that's a cute
Jenner neutral baby they think oh what a
cute boy
so my theoretical understanding of
gender and my parenting world collided
hard yes I want a diversity of colors
and toys from my childhood experience
I want a balanced environment for her to
explore and my sense of in her own way
we even picked a gender-neutral name for
our female born child but Jenner
neutrality is much easier as a
theoretical endeavor that
as a practice and in my attempts to
create gender neutrality I was
inadvertently pillaging masculinity over
femininity
so rather than toning down or
eliminating femininity in our lives we
make a concerted effort to celebrate it
we have pinks among the variety of
colors we balance out the cutes with
hansoms and the pretties with Strong's
and smarts and work really not hard not
to associate any words with gender we
value femininity and masculinity while
also being highly critical of it and do
our best and to not make her feel
limited by gender roles and we do all
this in hopes that we model a healthy
and empowered relationship with gender
for our kid now this work to develop a
healthy relationship with gender for
Elliot made me rethink and evaluate how
I allowed sexism to manifest and my own
gender identity I began to reevaluate
how I was rejecting femininity in order
to live up to a masculinity that was not
healthy or something I wanted to pass on
doing this self work meant I had to
reject option one I couldn't ignore and
move on I had to choose option two I had
to engage with some of my most
uncomfortable parts to move towards my
most authentic self and that meant I had
to get real about the discomfort I have
with my body now it's pretty common for
trans people to feel uncomfortable in
their body and this discomfort can range
from debilitating to annoying and
everywhere in between and learning my
body and how to be comfortable in it as
a trans person has been a lifelong
journey I've always struggled with the
parts of my body that can be I can be
defined as more feminine my chest my
hips my voice and I've made that
sometimes hard sometimes easy decision
to not take hormones or have any
surgeries to change it to make myself
more masculine by society's standards
and while I certainly haven't overcome
all the feelings of dissatisfaction I
realized that by not engaging with that
discomfort and coming to a positive and
affirming place with my body I was
reinforcing sexism transphobia and
modeling body shaming if I hate my body
in particular the parts society deems
feminine or female I potentially a limit
or damage how my kid can see the
possibilities of her body and her
feminine and female parts if I hate Arum
uncomfortable with my body how can I
expect my kid to love hers now it would
be easier for me to choose option one
to ignore my kid when she asked me about
my body or to hide it from her but I
have to choose option two every day I
have to confront my own assumptions
about what a dad's body can and should
be so I work every day to try and be
more comfortable in this body and in the
ways I express femininity so I talk
about it more I explore the depths of
this discomfort and final anguish that I
feel comfortable with and this daily
discomfort helps me build both agency
and authenticity and how I show up in my
body and in my gender I'm working
against limiting myself I want to show
her that a dad can have hips a dad
doesn't have to have a perfectly flat
chest or even be able to grow facial
hair and when she's developmentally able
to I want to talk to her about my
journey with my body I wanted to see my
journey towards authenticity even when
it means showing her than Messier parts
we have a wonderful pediatrician and
have established a good relationship
with our kids doctor and as you all know
while your doctor stays the same your
nurses and nurse practitioners change it
in and out and when Elliot was first
born we took her to the pediatrician we
met our first nurse we'll call her Sarah
now very early in on our time with Sarah
we told her how I was gonna be called
dad and my partner is mama
Sarah was one of those folks that took
it in stride and our subsequent visits
went pretty smoothly and about a year
later Sarah switched shifts and we
started working with a new nurse will
call her Becky we didn't get in front of
the dad conversations and it didn't
actually come up until Sarah our
original nurse walked in to say hi now
Sarah's warm and bubbly it said hi to
Elliot and me and my wife and when
talking to Elliot said something like
did your daddy holding your toy now the
corner of my eye I could see Becky
swinging around in her chair and make
dad gross as Sarah and as a conversation
shifted to our pediatrician I saw Sarah
and Becky's interaction continued and I
went something like this
Becky shaking your head no and mouthing
the word mom back Sarah shaking your
head no and mouthing word no dad no so
this went back and forth and total
silence a few more times until we walked
away now this interaction has stuck with
me Sarah could have chosen option one
ignored Becky and let her refer to me as
mom it would have been easier for Sarah
she could have put the response
ability back on me or not said anything
at all but in that moment she chose
option two she chose to confront the
assumptions and affirm my existence she
assisted that a person who looks and
sounds like me can in fact be a dad and
in a small but meaningful way advocated
for me my authenticity and my family
unfortunately we live in a world that
refuses to acknowledge trans people and
the diversity of trans people in general
and my hope is that when confronted with
an opportunity to stand up for someone
else we all take action like Sarah even
when there's risk involved so some days
the risks of being a genderqueer dad
feels too much and deciding to be a dad
has been really hard and I'm sure it
will continue to be the hardest yet most
rewarding experience of my life but
despite this challenge every day has
felt a hundred percent worth it so each
day I affirm my promise to Elliott and
that same promise to myself to love her
and myself hard with forgiveness and
compassion with tough love and with
generosity to give room for growth to
push beyond comfort in hopes of
attaining and living a more meaningful
life I know in my head and in my heart
that they're hard and painful and
uncomfortable days ahead my head and my
heart also know that all of it will lead
to a more rich authentic life that I
could look back on without regrets thank
you
[Applause]